hey Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm and today we are talking
about frac poles or black poles so why
would you use a rack pole or a black
bulb in your training
first things first for a lot of tall
lifters they tend to have issues getting
down to the bar when it's on the floor
because keep in mind the height that a
deadlift starts off the ground is kind
of an arbitrary number just based on the
diameter of a 45-pound plate so relative
to body height it starts a little bit
higher above the ground for shorter
people and a little bit lower to the
ground for taller people so you know if
you're mid six feet tall then you doing
a deadlift for the 45 pound plate maybe
you know similar to someone who's 5 feet
tall doing a deadlift that's elevated 3
or 4 inches off the ground just relative
to body proportions so obviously if you
plan on competing in powerlifting you
need to get comfortable dead lifting
from the floor but especially for
learning the movements and even for your
whole training career if you don't have
competitive aspirations there's really
no reason for you to not do rack
deadlifts simply if that's a range of
motion that you're more comfortable with
so that's number one number two is for
learning the dead lifting movement a lot
of people will find that they can
control their lumbar spine in their
pelvic positions through a certain range
of hip flexion but then when they go
beyond that range their lower back tends
to round they tend to go into posterior
pelvic tilt which really isn't a good
idea especially under heavy load
so rack deadlifts can be very useful for
those people I'm starting at a rack
height that you can control your lumbar
position and then slowly working down as
you gain that motor control so that's
number two the third reason that you
might want to use them is simply to
overload the movement a lot of people
find that especially for high
apples not necessarily above-the-knee
but about the upper third of the shin
they tend to be able to pull more than
they can pull from the floor that can be
beneficial for people especially who the
deadlift tends to get in their head and
a particular number is intimidating them
if you can load that weight on the bar
and pull it even if it's through a
partial range of motion then when you
see that weight on the bar on the floor
it tends to be slightly less
intimidating and the last reason is to
increase training frequency a lot of
people especially those who aren't built
particularly well for deadlifts tend to
find that deadlifts from the floor are
quite a stressful movement and can you
know a hard deadlift workout can knock
you back three or four days can be
really difficult to recover from so by
either doing either a bulk of your
training for block pulls or alternating
pulls from the floor and block poles or
rack pulls you can train the movement
more frequently and also a hard deadlift
workout won't detract quite as much from
say squat workouts later in the week
where if you would have pulled from the
floor your low back may still be sore
and that could still be impacting other
lower body work later in your training
week the next thing we're going to talk
about our different styles of rack pulls
or block pulls the first type is pulls
from above the knee these tend to not
have hardly any correlation to what you
can pull from the floor they're very
good for building upper back extreme and
mass because you can typically pull a
lot more than you can from the ground
but in terms of actually strengthening
you through that entire range of motion
there tends to not be very much
carryover for example I've pulled 725
from the floor and my best high rack
pull starting from a couple inches above
my knee is 805 I believe 8:05 815 but I
know people with deadlifts in the mid
fives who can rack pull low eighths from
that same height the high rack Bulls do
tend to be a very good hypertrophy
exercise especially for your
absent upper back they make you look
sweet but they don't necessarily make
you that much stronger now don't let me
decide you from doing high rack polls
simply by saying it's not going to
improve your deadlift from the floor
very much because those big ol sweet
bang traps that's a very noble training
goal and it could still give you a
competitive advantage if it scares your
competition so those are black polls or
rap polls from above the knee the other
type obviously by process of elimination
are pulls from below the knee if you're
doing rack polls for transference to
powerlifting trying to improve your
deadlift from the floor that's where you
should be doing them from most of the
time a lot of people will actually find
that they can deadlift more from the
floor than they can from mid-shin
typically people can pull a little bit
more from just below the knee than they
can from the floor but then when you get
to 3 4 inches lower than that to where
the bars only elevated 2 to 4 inches off
the ground a lot of people can actually
pull more from the floor the reason for
that is when the bars starting all the
way on the ground you have more knee
flexion so you can get more assistance
from your quads in breaking the bar off
the ground and getting some speed going
so if you have a sticking point just
below your knee then getting that bar
speed going with the assistance of your
quads can help you get through that
sticking point whereas if you're
starting with the bar elevated slightly
off of the ground you have to start the
lift almost entirely with your posterior
chain and then you can't get quite as
much speed going hitting that sticking
point however especially if that applies
to you you'll probably find that rack
pulls from below the knee do improve
your deadlift max quite a bit simply
because that is a significant weakness
if you shorten the range of motion and
you're still weaker than you work
through the full range of motion you'll
probably find that doing those rack
pulls or black pools helps you build
more horsepower through that sticking
point so then when you have that added
strength and then throw in a little
extra bar speed from assistance for your
from your quads when you pull off the
ground again you'll probably find that
it helps her
and the last way to implement black
polls or rattles is Bob people's style
if you don't know who Bob people's is
he's a legend in the strength game he
was the first man to deadlift 700 pounds
and he did it at a body weight of only
about 170 whereas everyone else in the
race to 700 tended to be like 300-pound
monsters he had some very innovative
training techniques and the main one he
used to build his deadlift was
progressive range of motion training and
how he did that basically is he would
have a bar loaded and he would dig a
hole and he would stand in the hole and
deadlift the bar and then every day he
would put a little more dirt in the hole
and slowly fill it up so eventually he
was standing on the same level as the
bar again
and then he'd just add more weight on
the bar dig the hole again and repeat
the process this is something that it's
not quite as popular now as it used to
be but personally the biggest jump I've
seen in my deadlift in well since I got
my initial newbie gains in the deadlift
was actually you utilizing this style of
training I was doing sumo rack pulls I'm
a conventional deadlift er but for a
while I went over to the dark side
before I came back to the light
conventional poles are cooler keep that
in mind you may pull more sumo and a big
powerlifting total is also cool but just
in terms of what raises your
testosterone the most gets you the most
groupies it's definitely conventional so
just like advice anyway so I briefly
cashed in my man cart and started
pulling sumo and I was quite a bit
weaker off the ground then I was from
mid-shin there was a much bigger
difference there than there was for
conventional so I did a lot of sumo rack
pulls and I did them about people style
I started from slightly above the knee
and then every week I would lower the
bar by about an inch or so until I was
pulling from about 3 inches off the
ground and then
I would add more weight on the bar and
start back from slightly above my knee
and it actually didn't help my so
deadlift any at all
it put maybe 10 pounds on it but then on
a whim when I was starting to get
frustrated with my sumo I just went back
to conventional and randomly pulled a 30
pound PR my previous PR had been 645 and
I basically speed wrapped 675 which was
entirely unexpected and then two days
later when I was fresh I came in and
pulled 725 and so yeah that was like an
80 pound PR from not training
conventional at all and just doing this
progressive range of motion sumo rack
pulls certainly not saying that I can
guarantee an 80 pound PR for you but
just something to keep in the back of
your mind especially if your deadlift
training has been getting stale
progressive range of motion rack polls
can be a fun way to inject some life
into your deadlift training alright guys
that's it thanks for watching the video
if you liked it and you'd like to see
more please like and subscribe if you
have questions ask them in the comments
below if you'd like to see me make a
video about a particular topic leave
those suggestions in the comments as
well and if I like it I may make a video
about it and if not I won't but I still
love you alright guys peace